[Music]
and for us to get better we're gonna
have to go through a lot of losses just
like that professional dining room just
like those boxers who've been hit by a
punch that they didn't see and we get
punched a lot but the nice thing is not
like the divers and not like boxers
we actually don't get injured this is
really good maybe a little bit of a loss
of confidence in a little lumpy but I
like to show you a game I played I was
white and I was very nervous it was the
one the first games I ever ever played
in a scholastics tournament okay and I
knew I was up against a guy who was
fearsome so I had to come up with a plan
and it better be a good one because this
guy's real hell on wheels you know so
here it comes you're ready this is this
is the birth of an international
Grandmaster superstar you're about to
see her and if you can see any genius
you are a genius because this is awful
so I started to think okay what I'm
going to do is I'm going to copy my
opponents move whatever move my
opponents make I'm gonna copy right and
then when he makes a mistake I'll jump
on him you know because he will good but
I had a problem I had to make the first
move like how can I copy my boat and if
I gotta make the first move so I got to
come up with a plan that's really deep
conceptual insightful clever brilliant
genius I got a move that doesn't injure
my position and allows me to copy my
opponent I played e3 I was white once
again I played e3 waiting I was so happy
boy this kid who I was playing he may
been a monster but he played exactly the
move I wanted to play because then I
could copy him yes yes boy I mean I
really knew what was happening now you
know now I was my confidence soared at
this moment okay
and he played him the remarkable move he
pushes pond Wow I had an awareness they
may have been small
I had an awareness I could take that
pond but that would have completely
defeated my genius insightful idea of
copying my appalling never doubt never
does up to you young man what are you
going to do what are you going to do I'm
ready for you he played another
remarkable move what is that Bishop g4
he attacks my queen well if I had any
competence whatsoever
I would simply have captured his Bishop
but I didn't think the moment was quite
right okay I did you know I got to give
him a little bit more rope to hang
himself right so Bishop g5 I mean move
removed like a boy I really felt like I
didn't know what was coming next but I
thought this was going to be wild and
this of course is a terrible move I mean
my opponent without hesitation
should take my bishop with his queen
I may have hesitated but I wouldn't
losing my queen
after taking his bishop that he played
the most remarkable move ever in my
tournament game history
he played Bishop before checkmate
okay like checkmate that was like oh man
that's wild
checkmate oh that was you
he checkmated me a moment before what a
checkmate adhere it so he raises his
hands and he pulls over an adult like
Ben over there and he says i checkmated
and you the adult says to my opponent
what why is it checkmate and my opponent
happily explains that this bishop
attacks the king while this bishop takes
away that square it takes a way that's
square the King can't move it's
checkmate yes says the adult that's
right we shake hands never mind the fact
that I can block the vision with this
pawn I could block the vision with this
night I could block it with his knife I
could even bring this bishop back or I
could even move my queen Wow so this is
the birth of an international
Grandmaster superstar do you see any
talent on the white player your genius
idea this guy's a complete idiot even
even accepted that he was checkmated
when he wasn't okay so I'd like to say
that I have made every mistake
conceivable in chess and most often I
make the same mistake at least twice not
once but twice
why twice well if you only make it one
time how can you be absolutely certain
it was a mistake you need to make it
twice to say yeah that really really is
a bad idea I'm not going to do it
anymore
okay so I made a lot of mistakes and I
can tell you that copying your opponent
is a really really packed idea okay
another attempt by me to copy my
opponent I was black in this
okay let me just let me just point out
this one this was really cool and I
still very strongly under the influence
of like my experience opponents they'll
show me the way I'll repeat whatever it
is that they did I my opponent played
efore I play e5 okay I even Steven your
turn they would play Knight f3 mmm Wow
okay cool he brings out his Knight I got
to bring up my night my opponent would
take my pawn by the way
unbeknownst to me I'm playing what is
called the petrov defense or even the
russian defense that has two names in
the West the Petrov defense is what we
call it in the East and Russia it's
called the Russian defense so I'm
playing the Russian defense I didn't
know it I take his pawn now at this
point I'm going to tell you I was a lot
better player than I was in the game
before and my opponent played Queen e2
and hye-won uh-oh I see this one come
and I got I got this one under control I
want to play Queen e7 and I I really I
did that I realized that after Queen e7
Queen takes my knight I can't take his
Knight I'll lose my queen don't didn't
want that no no no way so I move back my
knight see see how much better I had
become right I'd move back my knight so
that he couldn't take my knight and I
didn't fall for getting my Queen tracked
now my opponent played a shocking move
could anybody tell me what my opponent
did and lady
yeah knight c6 check Oh remember a
moment ago I was trying to avoid losing
my career and I lost my queen it was
like man that that was really terrible
uh I I blocked the check with my queen
he took the Queen and lost another one
another game right down the down the
drain and so what I had to do literally
was go through a progression of losses
and I started knowing that I was getting
better not so much because I was losing
I was always losing but it was taking my
opponents a little bit longer to defeat
me instead of losing in four five six
moves like this I mean I'm lost now he
he might take 20 moves or something for
him to win but he would win but I was
taken I was forcing my opponents to play
longer games and they were had to play
better and better you lose your queen
like this twice you stop doing it
okay here was another one this this this
was a this was a cool one this game
happened right next to me my best friend
his name was David Lee Oh Steph rack in
he what Leo was playing right next to me
and Leo was black and his opponent
opened up with what was called the
Queen's pawn opening and uh Leo he liked
to he liked the gambit called the
budapest gambit how many of you know
this gambit the budapest gambit okay
well like its namesake
peste or Buddha pêche is the capital
city of Hungary and in Budapest this it
seemed like this became a popular
defense amongst the locals and so it
bears the name of Budapest so this pawn
is captured the Night Moves here
Leo's opponent played here here here all
of these are absolutely standard moves
in the Budapest in this position white
actually has a choice 92 the move that
Leo's opponent played is fine Knight c3
is considered a better attempt a more
aggressive attempt by white to gain an
advantage so with the move 92 we add up
one two three one two three four five
looks like White's doing fine in the
development count Leo played Queen g7
and this was an excellent move by Leo he
simply wants to recapture his pawn and
get back material equality Leo's
opponent he started thinking and he
decided that his best move was to attack
Leo's Bishop he played a three and I was
shocked I was really shocked because I
was watching the game and I wanted my
buddy Leo to win I don't want to see him
lose and get then I have to deal with a
crying guy right so I wanted Leo to move
his bishop and to capture this Knight
and then to recapture the pond so that
he would be in safety and he wouldn't be
down any material Leo shot me
and he took this pawn and I was thinking
dude didn't you see that your opponent
just attacked your bishop how could you
be blind right like how could you be
blind I mean you did all understand that
that move a three attacked the bishop
right you saw that you saw that right
but the bishop it yeah - and I thought
so his opponent captured the bishop and
I was like oh man how could you allow
that I you know you just blundered a
piece and Leo made a devastating move
are you all familiar with this move do
you need Michael well you know did you
ladies know them what's the what's the
move yeah whoa
ninety three checkmate I mean here I
thought Leo had just lost a bishop for
absolutely zilch
and what a checkmate that is okay keep
in mind that for me the way I won games
it was very simple I had to wipe out all
my opponents army and then whatever I
had left then I hope I could checkmate
with that but the idea that you could
check made in one how many moves was
this this wasn't this wasn't that many
moves one for black two for black three
four five six seven eight lose check me
are you
I knew the fools mate and I knew the
stupid stupid me when he did stupid
stupid things
I knew the stupid stupid mate but I
didn't know this kind of pattern and
it's really a charming one and the
amazing thing about this pattern
is it comes up time and time it it
reoccurs often if you don't believe me
look at this example e4od for go up
Kelly for c6 new variation d4 d5 Knight
c3 pawn tags 90s right here Queen here
so why in this move moment when black
plays this move what he wants to do is
bring his knight here and force a trade
but he doesn't want to have a double
pawn so black plays Knight d7 white
plays Queen e2 laying an amber okay very
simple ambush maybe it's easier when we
see it from whites point of view and
white is hoping that black follows
through with his plan so he can do the
same night smothered checkmate rule
right and so these types of smother
checkmates occur very very often in a
wide wide range of positions one other
position I'm going to just create there
so this was this is a composition
obviously but it happens so many times
in openings this is one of those I
probably didn't fall for once or twice
or three times or four times I really
had to be sure about this one so I
probably was victimized five times like
this one I mean because sometimes I
forgot to write I mean okay so here's
the point yeah no worries okay so I want
a I took upon so we get a position like
this and
I was really greedy oh I love my queen
my queen was the bully and I always
strongly felt if I could get my queen
completely the worst idea in chess by
the way is to develop your queen early
you I was always thinking if I could get
my Queen out I could I could do great
things so this was one of the great
things that I could do was win upon so I
was like just overjoyed to have a
position like this as black okay and I
fell for this like I said not once twice
I'm talking like five times do you know
the checkmate for white that white can
come up with here this is an oldie but a
goodie yes young lady
Bishop c3 is an excellent move it's an
excellent move because it threatens
Queen d8 checkmate it attacks the Queen
so probably this is like the best black
can do is take the bishop and he's lost
so Bishop c3 is an excellent move and
under normal circumstances that would be
the best move it just so happens there's
one there's one
dirty dirty move I think you had it what
do you see yeah baby like okay when this
when this one was first played against
me like I mean this is like a cold
shower like rural I mean the Queen isn't
even protected it's like she didn't even
capture nothing this isn't a trade this
is somebody just blundering their Queen
so I would take the Queen yeah
okay and now and instantly the computer
showed you the the power of the double
check double check simply mean you can't
block you can block the rook but you
can't block the bishop at the same time
you can block the bishop your king has
to move and in this position you have
absolutely no choice the King here and
then comes the checkmate Wow
how cool is that and of course the idea
and principle idea and so many openings
is your starting chess your learning and
you know your opponent is going to know
a lot of patterns and chests that you
don't know so it's going to take you a
lot of Falls before you learn to ride
and one of the things about the
chessboard at the starting position that
you really have to look at is you look
at this starting position and you say
you okay you're the general of your army
so where are you going to focus your
attack where are you going to bring your
pieces well it would be really
ridiculous for you to focus your army on
this pawn on d7 or this pawn on e7 why
well because those two pawns are the
strongest defenses in Blacks camp this
pawn on d7 is protected by the king the
Queen the bishop in the night for
protections this pawn the king the Queen
the bishop and that night for
protections every other pawn on the
board has a single protector so you're
much better off targeting any of those
other pawns besides these two now it
turns out that if you were to target
this pawn on a7 let's say with your
opening
moves you came out with the brilliant
idea okay new variation of going after
your opponent's a7 pawn I loops part
knee I'm just putting some moves on the
board for a moment g6 so Bishop use them
Bishop takes a sell yippee ai-yay yippee
you won upon you you brought your forces
and boy you sure didn't NAB that pawn
well besides the fact that this was a
disastrous idea the knight could attack
your Queen and Bishop you literally won
the wrong pawn you won upon but there
was no reward at the end of that rainbow
now if you had been a little bit
cleverer in your opening you might have
thought to yourself D fine I'll do
something else new variation here here
here here here this had a greater reward
yes baby this time you won the pawn on
c7 but at the end of the rainbow there
was a queen to be had here you've won
brilliantly of course black should not
have allowed this to happen but we're
not it dresser that what we're
interested in is is this idea of
targeting certain pawns and of course it
becomes instantly obvious that the f2
pawn and the f7 pawn there's such a a
magnet for our pieces because in both
cases this pawn is protected by the King
this pawn is protected only by the King
and if we could win that pawn well we
could win the game and checkmate so one
of my favorite patterns I'm sure you all
know this this is called the Frome's
gambit
by the way white does a terrible thing
especially when starting he advances the
pond that is simply the most vulnerable
pond he plays F for and instantly
exposes his King to danger black does
this pawn takes d6 pawn takes Bishop
tangs so black sacrificed upon and the
first time this pattern was shown to me
it was like really gleeful right wow
this was really cool okay white does not
understand the threat and plays Knight
c3 misses completely the whole point so
the whole point is this pawn on f2 is
key critical in fact to the defense
protection of whites King black jumps
all over this check okay
g3
cleant eggs now some of them you may
object and say well why didn't you
capture with the bishop and then you
would have had a queen
well aesthetically it's nicer to
checkmate with it anybody can check mate
with a queen the check mating with a
bishop boy that's that's really elegant
and first-class
so this checkmate really made a powerful
impression on me I never ever got
anybody into this particular but I knew
the gambit all of these patterns that
I'm showing you guess what I only
learned about them through my experience
of losing them and one of the ways I had
to teach myself chess and I strongly
advise it to everybody is to keep a
chess scrapbook let's say somebody gives
you a puzzle one says can you checkmate
the King and three moves and the
solution is wild something that really
really inspires you well take that
puzzle put it in your chest grab book I
felt very strongly in my life that
somebody said to me you know light the
number of moves in a chess game is like
10 to the 56th power or something like
that
that's 10 with 56 zeroes oh my gosh my
brains too small I could never imagine
storing all of those moves in my brain I
had to find a shortcut and the shortcut
I found is what I just showed you these
patterns of smothered mates these
patterns of double check and checkmate I
wouldn't write the I would write them in
a notebook my scrapbook bun and I would
keep them my absolute favorite my
favorite checkmating combination is
called la Gauls mate how many of you
know the Gauls made it's marvellous
stuff ah
it's marvelous and this was really
really inspiring and it's a pity I
memorize this obviously now this move
the Philidor defense it's a little
second-rate defense but nothing terrible
now don't ask me why but to get to La
Liga late Black has to make an egregious
error here I mean like really blows it
he plays a turkey Turkey of a move I
mean this isn't this is like a howler
how many of you know what a howler is
how a howler is a move that's so bad
that your cries of anguish can be heard
from the next County if that's a howler
so black plays this howler h6 and my
teacher said white plays Knight takes e5
and I want what are you crazy you can't
take that pawn you'll lose the Queen
take your move back I was being a
generous person I said take your move
back Geoffrey Geoffrey says go ahead if
you like go ahead and take my queen do
you see the move for white young lady
what Bravo I mean I I knew about Knight
forks in fact I was pretty pretty
hellacious where those Knight Forks were
concerned I knew that when the night
came here he would attack the Queen in
fact the rook and I get the rook or when
the knight would come to c7 it attacked
that King and I get that room so I knew
all about Knight fork so this move was a
real surprise because I expected my
opponent to make a knight fork and to
take on f7 with the knight Geoffrey
my opponent with my chess teacher chess
coach so I was looking at so where can I
move my king
I can't move my King to d7 it's
protected by the knight my bishops in
the way my Queens in the way I can't
take that bishop I got to move King e7
so after I move King e7 what's White's
move I'm afraid young man Knight d5 whoa
checkmate in the middle the Lord boy I
was so excited I wrote that in my
notebook I memorized it now stop and
think about this you got chess moves 10
to the 56th power and I memorized one of
the sequences and I never in my whole
life got a chance to play it no that's
not just cruel and unfair you know Here
I am a 12 year old kid just begging
somebody to let me play this just please
somebody never even close
like nobody played the Philidor nobody
played the howler nobody let me
sacrifice my queen so there it is I'll
leave again with this message of this
thought that when you lose a chess
really what's happening is you're losing
to a more experienced player who knows
patterns better than you do really
that's what it comes down to I may be
more skilled but where those skills come
from is from a lifetime of losses don't
worry about the losses worry about the
patterns don't keep making the same
mistakes and losing in the same way help
yourself help your memory by creating a
scrapbook in your scrapbook make make
notes okay this is an oldie
goody it absolutely became my favorite
favorite because nobody ever let me play
the Gauls mate this is called the
smothered mate and the first time this
pattern was shown to me what happened is
I was so excited I ran home to my mom my
mom was in the kitchen doing her dishes
doing the dishes not her dishes our
dishes the dishes and I said mom come on
over I got to show you this on the chess
board and I showed her the pattern back
and forth and she goes wow that's great
can I go back to the dishes like well I
mean how come you're not as excited
about what did I did I mean you know if
well what can I tell you some people
they just don't get it okay so in this
position obviously black is winning
tremendously in the material he's got
like a rook for a knight so he's an
exchange up but he's got an extra rug
and there's issues on the back rank so
whites in deep deep trouble except he
has this Queen Czech Queen defy check
the King cannot go to f8 because of the
simple
checkmate thanks to the fact the knight
supports the Queen Black has chat mated
so black has to go to the corner okay so
this is where things got interesting
night check King here and here I thought
the knight could move and it's just a
repetition right that it's a draw that
black can't avoid perpetual check and
white should be very happy because after
all he's a rook behind and exchange
behind you should be happy to get out of
Dodge with a draw from from a material
behind do you all know this combination
I love this combination night h6 double
check so cool so cool the King cannot
must go into the corner once again if
the King goes to f8 this is the same
checkmate as before the queen is
supported protected by the knight the
King has to go in the corner Queen
sacrifices herself Queen g8 check rook
takes Knight f7
I was charmed by this pattern in this
pattern I have probably played and I'm
not kidding in tournament games 50 times
in blitz games just fun games probably
closer to 300 so this pattern now this
is a useful pattern that Legault made
I'll kick that one right out of my
scrapbook from now on but this one is
one you can really really really use and
it occurs in all kinds of positions so
when you're making your scrapbook look
out for those checkmating patterns
especially as they come out of the
openings because once and again when you
lose you're losing to people who are
more experienced than no more patterns
than you do so you can play catch-up by
number one playing more reading studying
and of course remembering there aren't
that many patterns as you may think
there's only about oh I'd say 2030 check
mating pattern
[Music]